the moment of impact no one disputes the
devastation when a Ukrainian passenger
plane smashed to earth in Iran but this
disagreement about why it happened the
Iranian authorities say they thought a
technical failure on board was to blame
but now US officials suspect an Iranian
missile shot it out the sky most likely
by accident Canada who lost 63 of its
citizens in the crash agrees we have
intelligence from multiple sources
including our allies and our own
intelligence the evidence indicates that
the plane was shot down by an Iranian
surface-to-air missile this may well
have been unintentional president Donald
Trump also has doubts about the crash I
have my suspicions it was flying in a
pretty rough neighborhood and somebody
could have made a mistake some people
say it was mechanical I personally don't
think that's even a question
the crash happened hours after Iran
launched a barrage of missiles against
us targets in Iraq it made the tragedy
an extraordinary coincidence
speculation swirled online that an air
defense missile might be to blame
these images are part of a russian-made
surface-to-air missile were circulated
on social media experts in verification
however are yet to confirm if they're
genuine or when or where they were taken
this is the site of an airliner that was
brought down by a missile over Ukraine
six years ago
the investigative website Belling cat
shot to fame for work it did identifying
the missile involved do you think it's
more likely that this was brought down
by a missile it's just too early to say
either way what this looks like one of
the possibilities down but before we
make that determination we really have
to be careful we have to take our time
verify the images so that we ensure
Ukrainian flight PS 752 took off from
Tehran
at 6:10 local time on Wednesday morning
Iranian investigators say it caught fire
and tried to turn back then disappeared
from the radar at about 8,000 feet
that's 2400 meters just a few minutes
after takeoff and crashed near the city
of pur and US officials claimed the
aircraft was hit by a missile possibly a
russian-made tore m1 Tehran dismissed
the missile theory as illogical rumor
but Ukraine wants independent answers
and has sent its own team of
investigators the task is clear to
understand what happened
unfortunately for today we cannot know
for sure whether it was a terrorist act
or whether it was some other event our
task is to put an end to this issue
they'll want access to this what appears
to be the black box flight recorder
Britain too is urging a credible and
transparent investigation for British
nationals were among the 176 people on
board the plane if a missile strike is
confirmed it would be a huge
embarrassment for Iran it would also be
another tragic twist in it bitter
dispute with America
Deborah Haynes Sky News